steve kaufman
um today i want to announce my new um
routine my new uh sort of
concept of language learning uh which i
want to call five days to fluency
five days to fluency now there's been a
certain amount of
discussion on the web
about whether we can achieve fluency in
three months and there's a young
gentleman in new york who has
learned an astonishing number of
languages in a few weeks and
and there's daniel tamet
who learns icelandic in a week or 10
days and so there are examples of uh and
of course benny with his three months to
some level in chinese we're not quite
sure what
uh
so what can we so so with all of this
discussion about three months to fluency
i sat down and thought about it and i
decided that in fact it's five days
five days now you might say well first
of all what is fluency i think that's
the important thing to first of all to
define
so i'll tell you what my view is
i think fluency means the ability to
speak comfortably on a wide variety of
subjects
to understand most of what is being said
by natives in a conversation
to be able to participate in that
conversation in such a way that the
native speaker
feels that you understand and is not at
all concerned that you don't understand
and you don't have to
ask the native speaker to repeat and
that includes talking about sports
politics literature philosophy
possibly not technical subjects like
fixing your car you know but a wide
variety of subjects and fluency in my
mind
refers to speaking uh
because the fluency is flowing it's the
speaking
so i don't think we need to apply it
across all skills
uh however i think it's very difficult
to be fluent without also being able to
read well it's not necessary that you'll
be able to write well but to be able to
read well and you can make mistakes and
still be fluent in my opinion and i have
done business with many people from many
countries who are very fluent who have
no difficulty doing who are very
effective who express themselves better
than many native speakers and who are
fluent therefore but still make mistakes
so making mistakes is not the issue so
that is fluency now why would i say five
days to fluency well
one reason is it sounds good you know f
like five days to fluency it kind of
flows
uh that's one good reason
uh but seriously i also believe it
and i'm going to prove it
i'm going to prove that i can do it and
i'm going to do it with check
now you're going to say well you've
already been studying check well exactly
that's the point so i'm going to explain
what i mean by five days to fluency and
that is this
i believe
that uh in learning a language we have
to put as you all know if you've been
following my channel we have to put a
lot of emphasis in building up our
language potential that is our ability
to understand our familiarity with the
language our vocabulary
we review grammar in different ways at
different times without ever trying to
ace it but it's all helping us
acquire a sense of comfort and
confidence and a potential in the
language
but that doesn't mean yet that we can
speak
and fluency means the ability to speak
now i believe that if you prepare
yourself properly
that if you then go
to the country or put yourself in a
situation where for five solid days you
are totally immersed in the language you
speak the language you hear the language
you read the language but particularly
you speak it because you've been doing a
lot of listening and reading now you've
got to be in a position in a situation
where you have to speak it eight or more
hours a day that those are those those
are the key five days now for that to be
successful
a you have to prepare yourself so lots
of input you can even do some dry runs
of a day or two where you're doing
nothing but reading in your target
language
you can have some discussions as i'm
having some online discussions in check
but i'm stumbling terribly i mean i
really can't put too many words together
uh but you have to do that and you you
do that until you reach the point where
you think now i'm good enough and this
is the key point that when i say i go to
prague i've got to say within five days
i've got to be able to hold up my end of
a conversation on just about any subject
and so i've got to be confident that i
have reached you know that level in my
preparation or conversely i've now set
that as a goal because i'm going to
prague in the first week of october and
i want to prove that i can put enough
effort into preparing myself so that
five days there
i'm going to be able to catapult myself
into fluency now the next thing you have
to do is you have to organize and this
is what i'm going to try to do for my
visit in prague to prague you have to
organize conditions
you know
whatever conditions are necessary so
that you can be speaking the language
all day long you can't just show up in
the country and expect that you're going
to be able to find people to talk to so
i have to find friends people i know
tutors on link people who follow my blog
anyone i can find that i can meet up
with in prague so that for five days
i can speak check with these people
maybe i will enroll for example if you
can't find anyone um maybe i would make
maybe i'll make an appeal here on my
channel who in prague is willing to
spend some time with me maybe i have to
pay for private lessons maybe i have to
go to school but i have to be submerged
immersed in check for five days okay so
i have to prepare for it and i have to
make sure that the conditions are there
that are going to enable me to do it now
the third thing of course is the
follow-up
because the five days to fluency
it doesn't mean that on day five you're
fluent
you'll make a major breakthrough a major
step forward but i have always found
that in language learning there is this
gestation period it's it's like baking
bread in the oven
so
you make a major step forward during
these five days
but you will find that the
impact of these five days will continue
for quite a while so after you return
then
you will continue maintenance activities
reading and listening and occasionally
speaking and you'll find that that you
will continue to improve in your degree
of fluency
so i mean obviously if you have three
months to spend instead of five days
you'll do even better but i i like the
idea that you focus on this five-day
total immersion
you make
all the preparations necessary in terms
of your language study beforehand in
terms of the circumstances that will
prevail while you're there so that you
do get that solid immersion and then the
maintenance work that you do
after the fact so there you have it that
is my five days to fluency
program
uh and check will be the first test of
this
uh i've been at check now for about
eight months off and on
between you know leaving it to travel to
australia doing a bit of russian here
and there but
i'm on my check and i'm gonna crank it
up a bit although i am interspersing it
with russian i think as i get closer to
october i might stop doing my russian
focus on the check the objective being
that when i hit prague for five days i'm
going to speak nothing but check and as
a result i will convert myself from
someone who stumbles in the language
understands it quite well but stumbles
when speaking into someone
who maybe not on the fifth day but
soon thereafter will be
able to say
i am fluent in check we'll see what
happens and i look forward to your
feedback bye for now